y lo podemos ver en la primera diapositiva.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Inmediatamente tu razonamiento es "¿es ese un huevo cocido?"
(Risas)
"¿Es acaso la estructura integral de un huevo
que es capaz de soportar el peso de lo que parece ser una roca?
Ajá ¿es de hecho una roca de verdad?".
Nos hacemos preguntas cuando tenemos información visual,
pero cuando escuchamos información esto es lo que pasa.
(Risas)
Las compuertas de nuestra mente se abren tanto
como las calles de Shanghái.
(Aplausos)
Mucha información por procesar,
tantas ideas, conceptos, sentimientos y por supuesto vulnerabilidades,
que por lo regular no deseamos compartir.
Por eso nos escondemos
y nos ocultamos detrás de lo que conocemos como las compuertas de la intimidad.
(Risas)
¿Y qué será lo que esas compuertas sostienen?
¿Cuál será la presa sobre la que se construyó?
Bueno, primero que nada...
(Risas)
Encontramos que es diferente para seis genotipos distintos .
(Aplausos)
Por supuesto, podemos empezar por clasificar estos genotipos
como experiencias neuronormativas y experiencias neurodiversas.
(Risas)
Del lado derecho de la pantalla
notarán los incrementos en la forma de pensar neurodiversa.
Por lo general, hay solo dos estados emocionales
que un cerebro neurodiverso puede tabular y registrar en cualquier momento.
De este modo se elimina la posibilidad de que ellos se sientan, en ocasiones,
emocionalmente conectados con la situación del momento.
Pero en el lado izquierdo, pueden ver un cerebro neuronormativo
que puede manejar cerca de cinco tipos diferentes
de información cognitiva emocional en cualquier momento.
Estos son las pequeñas variaciones que observan
en los 75, 90 y 60 %.
y, por supuesto, la dramática diferencia
de 25, 40 y 35 %.
(Risas)
Pero ¿cuál es la red neuronal
que ayuda a generar estas diferentes discrepancias?
(Risas)
El miedo.
(Aplausos)
Como todos sabemos, el miedo reside en la amígdala.
Es una respuesta natural
y se encuentra muy conectada con la percepción visual.
No se encuentra tan conectada con la percepción verbal,
así que con frecuencia nuestros receptores del miedo
se apagarán con antelación ante cualquier uso cognitivo de las palabras
y señales del idioma.
Estos momentos de miedo
nos dejan desconcertados.
Vacilamos hacia cierta dirección,
por lo general, lejos de la intimidad.
(Risas)
Es claro que hay diferencias entre la percepción masculina
y la percepción femenina,
y de los trans y aquellos que están en medio,
y fuera del espectro de género.
(Risas)
El miedo es la parte básica principal
de todos nuestros sistemas de respuesta.
"Pelear o huir" es una de las primeras,
algunos dicen reptiliano, respuestas al entorno.
¿Cómo podemos desprendernos o desengancharnos de la amígdala?
(Risas)
Me gustaría compartir ahora con Uds. el secreto.
(Aplausos)
Todo esto tiene mucho, mucho sentido.
(Risas)
El secreto recae
en darnos la espalda unos a otros.
Sé que esto suena totalmente contradictorio
a lo que esperaban,
pero cuando en una relación le das la espalda a tu pareja
y pones tu espalda sobre la de ellos...
(Risas)
se eliminan los indicadores visuales.
(Aplausos)
Estarán más preparados
a fracasar primero,
y al fracasar primero...
(Risas)
supera con creces a lo que somos capaces de hacer
para agradar a los demás,
a nuestras parejas y a nosotros mismos.
Gastamos miles de millones de dólares
en ropa, maquillaje,
en los lentes que están de moda,
pero no invertimos tiempo y dinero
en conectarnos con los demás
de una manera verdadera
y honesta
y sin la necesidad de esos receptores visuales.
(Aplausos)
(Risas)
¿Parece difícil, no?
Queremos ser determinantes sobre esto.
No queremos dormirnos en nuestros laureles.
Hoy temprano un historiador mencionó
que es importante levantarse y en ocasiones eludir esos problemas.
¿Cómo lo podemos lograr?
El "ice" es una gran parte de eso.
Intuición, compasión y empatía
I, C, E.
(Aplausos)
Cuando empezamos a utilizar el método "ice",
las posibilidades se tornan más grandes que nosotros.
De hecho, se hacen más pequeñas que Uds.
A un nivel molecular
creo que esa visión
es el tema unificador
para cada charla que han visto en TED,
y continuaremos con el curso de este viaje
aquí en este pequeño planeta,
en la cornisa, en el precipicio,
tal como lo vemos, sí, la muerte es inevitable.
(Risas)
¿Nos llegará a todos al mismo tiempo?
Creo es la variable a nuestra interrogante.
(Risas)
Me parece que esa línea del tiempo se alargará un poco más
si aplicamos "ice",
nos apoyamos sobre las espaldas de los demás
y construimos juntos,
dejando de lado el miedo
y trabajando hacia...
(Risas)
ellos borrarán esta parte...
una experiencia madura de amor,
de compasión,
de intimidad basada en una verdad
que Uds. comparten desde los ojos de la mente
y el corazón que todos somos capaces de tocar,
de sentir táctilmente,
y tener una experiencia sentimental apabullante,
y que no la desechamos tan solo porque se ha oscurecido,
pero que nos permita dividir la experiencia que acumulamos,
que nos permita plantar en el corazón, el centro,
la semilla de esa idea en cada uno de nosotros
y compartirla entre nosotros.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)